Turkey's new offensive ads a volatile
extra dynamic to an already complex war
it followed Donald Trump's decision to
withdraw US troops a mood widely
condemned as a betrayal of America's
Kurdish allies Turkey sees the Kurdish
militias as a threat even though these
same fighters supported the u.s. in the
fight against Islamic state president
Erdogan has launched military action in
two Kurdish held parts of Syria before
such as jarred loose and athlean but
this latest push is by far the most
significant since September US troops
had conducted joint patrols with Turkish
soldiers along the border but now Ankara
wants to create a 30 kilometre deep zone
which turkey says should be used to
resettle up to two million Syrian
refugees one of the areas bomb today is
Ra's al ain which is in that zone and
Kurds there are warning that they may be
at risk of ethnic cleansing another
flashpoint are these camps president
Donald Trump has said Turkey will be
responsible for the thousands of Islamic
state suspects held in Syria under
Kurdish guard this is causing
significant concern in London and
elsewhere with Turkey saying each
country with is fighters must take
responsibility for them even though the
UK for example had previously said no